when you did
a movie like superman 3.
were you thinking i'm going to be i'm
part of this franchise this is going to
be a huge movie i'm working with all
these people this is going to be great
that kind of feeling
it was really exciting to get to work
with richard lester and chris
uh
how was that working with christopher he
was fantastic he was
so kind because i was coming in
i i think i i think they were just
really angry with margot kenner because
she was
causing them some grief i don't know how
or why and she's been the sweetest you
know she came to smallville and she was
so sweet but even then because i had
like
a couple of scenes with her that we shot
in one day wasn't easy and she was
incredible she was so welcoming
and she was friends with richard pryor
and and she introduced me to him and he
was so kind to me and just we sat on the
set and taught and he was so sweet
really yeah what a great moment yeah he
was amazing i remember we were in um
calgary and that was smallville that was
the the smallville always canada yeah
canada's always smallville
um and so i was there and it was all
that we're on it's a parade or something
going on i saw the movie one time when
it first came out so i don't remember a
lot but
it it i was on a
like a parade dais kind of thing and
he's up there dressed up like a general
richard pryor
um and so in between taxi we just sat
and talked he just wanna know about like
just the normal guy fun guy he was
asking me stuff like you're asking me
about my family and and my life and and
i was getting ready to get married and
um
we talked about that anyway he was just
lovely
so um
but chris reeve when i got so i was kind
of like a um
they wrote this part of lana because
they didn't have lois lana lang yeah
so i uh
i i got there and i had just finished
doing
a play i think i would just finish doing
no i was doing 48 hours at the same time
i just finished 48 hours and i got on
the plane got over there and immediately
like was taken to wardrobe and it was
just this whirlwind i mean it didn't
just happen overnight yeah yeah really
fast and met richard lester and and he's
like and i have this first scene and
it's all but but chris reeve invited me
to his home and he was had
his wife or his girlfriend and and uh
two little darling children and had we
had dinner and he took me to see simon
and garfunkel at wembley stadium wait a
minute and you didn't even really know
him i didn't know him at all and that
was just invite you to this wow
gave me food and tickets and you know
stuff and then we were shooting at um
uh pinewood and he he took me down to
the commissary and he said you just
start a tab for her here at the
commissary he's like i never went again
because you know
i bring my cheese and crackers from home
wow but um
he couldn't have been more generous and
sweet and then on the set and and so i
worked with him mostly as clark for like
weeks we did all the clark stuff right
and then i was coming to the set and i
was i was a superman comic fanatic as a
kid i would i would trade the comic
books i loved wow
i wasn't i wasn't a big superman believe
it
look at me horror movies
yeah you know yeah
that's posters yeah anyway oh my god
so anyway so the first time i i go on
the set and i didn't see him because he
had a separate room for him when he was
doing um
spelling superman because he had a lot
of different makeup and wig and kind of
stuff he had to put on and so i didn't
see him and and i i knew i was going to
work with him as superman i'd seen him
on screen as superman you know but i
hadn't
so i'm walking by in the in the we're
going to this to the set and the stage
is really dark and i i hear this voice
say hello annette
and i look to my right and i i look at
this it was like looking up a mountain i
looked
like that and i not i'm not kidding i i
started to i
kind of like stutter and and got chills
and just it was it was there was
superman it was dressed up he was in the
whole gear
and talking about it now i get chills
thinking about it wow it was amazing
because it was a thing from my childhood
and from watching movies and then from
knowing him but it was it was the first
time i really felt like
i don't know who that is he wasn't chris
reeve you know he was he was talking a
different way he had a totally different
kind of
energy about him
i don't think people realize what a
great actor he was he was a great i mean
somewhere in time is one of my favorite
movies yeah you know he could just
really turn it on he had this sweetness
this innate vulnerability to him right
oh he was wonderful